one of the claims Trump made during
these events was that we need to bring
religion back into the country now that
may come as a surprise to those who
realize not only has religion not left
the country we still have religious
influence in Government at the state and
federal level you regularly hear
religious arguments made during Civil
policy debates when it comes to abortion
or gay marriage or whatever the case may
be many of us wondering why is there so
much religion given that we're supposed
to have separation of church and state
Trump says we have to bring religion
back and we have to bring religion back
into our country because that's
something that's
that's something that is as you know
it's under it's under attack a lot of us
are under attack and we uh We're not
gonna we're gonna win yep bigger than
ever before we're going to bring
religion back people wondering where did
it go it seems to be very front and
center